hi I'm Mark cubin I'm here with BuzzFeed
and these are my thirst
tweets going on Shark Tank to ask Mark
cubin to spit on
me how much money you got I'm not just
immediately saying no it just
depends oh my goodness somebody tell
Mark Cuban's fine ass to call me I I I
don't think I'm going to call you but I
I like the idea and maybe someday I'll
just be able to say hello but I don't
think a call is in the cards right now
but thank you I need to have a thre Sim
with Mark cubin and Robert heric no
absolutely not it's not going to happen
oh my god I've smelled Robert's cologne
I've sat next to him on Shark Tank no
I'll even watch Shark Tank because Mark
cubin is the ultimate D thank you thank
you thank you with three teenagers who
just give me grief all day long to know
that I'm a d that makes my day going on
Shark Tank and proposing that Mark Cuban
let me him you know what I think that'd
be good good for the ratings I
definitely think you should apply and I
don't think I'd have any problem getting
past the ABC sensors you know it's a new
age New Generation let's bring it
abc.com sharktank Mark Cuban sex tape
now you're too late supposedly it
already happened I got sued because
somebody said I made a sex tape with Kim
Kardashian and about 18 other people
you're just going to have to find it
Mark Cuban has definitely had a threesim
and called it a Cuban sandwich right I
can neither confirm nor deny whether
I've been part of a Cuban sandwich
moving on Mark Cuban kinky as hell I'm
envisioning my hands tightening around
Mark Cuban's throat oh Mark Cuban like
no that was not me oh wait maybe it was
oh cuz you know what when I liked a
tweet saying I'm envisioning my hands
tightening around Mark Cuban's throat
that is me just saying
you I hate when guys ask me what's the
number one thing on your bucket list and
I have to be all cute and say something
like cross country road trip when it
really is to have Mark cubin punch me in
the face you know I hear that a lot it's
just one of those things I mean people
just like for me to spit on them choke
them punch them maybe it's a calling I
didn't know I had but no it's not going
to happen Okay shout out Mark cubin
that's big dick energy facts my pitch on
Shark Tank would be Mark cubin will you
kiss me on the lips I want to hear that
pitch I'm not going to say yes but I
definitely want to hear that pitch I
want mark Cuban as my baby daddy I would
bust it open for him without him even
asking fell in love with him on Shark
Tank also kind of in love with his bank
account seriously it's just about my
bank account you know better all you
like about me is my bank account nah I
want Mark cubin to spit on me he's so
[__] bad bro there's a theme
happening here that I don't know if I
like or not but once again make me an
offer Mark Cuban is my celebrity crush
like being a billionaire air and using
your wealth to help others zatty energy
big time well thank you that is my
mission in life if you can't have zatty
energy what do you have Mark Cuban can
get it for real when we say Eat the Rich
we're talking about his ass cheeks
scrumps Deli ises if it gets to that
point and somebody is eating the rich
definitely go for my ass cheeks because
Scrump Deli ishes I feel bad for you you
know go through all that stuff that's
hysterical though yeah your history must
be like insan insane cuz there's some
brutal people out there you found like
the nice
ones I just got to say these thirst
tweets were insane and I'm here for him
thank you I've been married 21 years and
loved every minute of it but there's
always room for a thirst tweet and while
we're speaking of thirst tweet thanks to
BuzzFeed for having me on and don't
forget to watch Shark Tank Friday nights
on ABC at 8:00 p.m. Eastern 700 p.m.
central because I guarantee you I'm
going to be talking to the producers the
minute I walk off this stage and some of
these thirst tweets are going to be
[Music]
there